if people want to watch movies like this
and continue to uh consume content
that isn't preaching a message to them
and
jamming a sort of a secular worldview
down their throats
then they have to support a conservative
economy
if you haven't heard yet get your
popcorn ready because daily wire is now
in the movie business
on this very exciting episode of the
sunday special i'm delighted to welcome
dallas sonia
the producer of daily wire's first film
run hide fight the story of a young girl
named zoe
who fights back against a group of
shooters who take over her high school
available now
only at dailywire.com raised
appropriately enough in dallas texas
dallas grew up wanting to make it in the
movies and eventually brought the movies
to him
getting the hell out of la and forming a
production company right in his hometown
making hollywood level work outside of
and unfiltered by hollywood
dallas started at talent agencies and
management firms repping major players
in the entertainment industry
from there he went on to found and
co-found several companies and produce
a staggering number of films over the
last decade including bone tomahawk
dragged across concrete the standoff at
sparrow creek and brawl in cell block 99
his newest company is bonfire legend
which has partnered with daily wear to
bring you
our badass new film in today's episode
you'll hear all about how this team up
first started
plus the journey dallas went through to
make run hide fight
[Music]
hey and welcome this is the ben shapiro
show sunday special today's show is
sponsored by expressvpn
thousands of my listeners have already
secured their internet join them at
expressvpn.com
ben just a reminder we'll be doing some
bonus questions at the end with dallas
the only way to get access to that part
of the conversation is to become a
member
head on over to dailywire.com become a
member you'll have access to all of the
full conversations with every one
of our awesome guests dallas thanks so
much for stopping by thank you for
having me well so we are about to embark
on uh
an excellent journey together so for
those who don't know
run hide fight is now available over at
dailywire.com we're going to talk all
about run hide fight where it came from
what the inspiration for it was but i
don't begin with
with you because people may not know you
or your work so
how did you get into the film industry
in the first place yeah well i grew up
in dallas texas and loved movies i went
to the movies with my dad
as a kid uh he would always let me see
r-rated films even when i was a little
kid
uh and so i just became enamored with uh
the industry and ended up
sort of becoming a big fan of the jerry
bruckheimer movies
uh top gun days of thunder and i
realized there was a job
called a movie producer and that there
was a school
that taught you film out at usc so i
just got enamored with that space
and ended up sort of putting all my
effort and energy into going west
to california and being in hollywood and
going to film school
and and pursuing my dreams and that's
how it got started most people
you know who have that idea they get off
the bus they end up as as baristas as a
coffee bean
and then they end up getting back on the
bus and leaving but that's obviously not
what happened
to you so how did you end up actually
fulfilling the dream of being able to
produce film well when i was a kid
i convinced usc film school to let me in
early
so i went as a 16 year old over the
summer and ended up with a semester of
classes before i returned as an 18 year
old for undergrad
and when i got there they had a
producing program
for graduates but not for undergrads
so i worked with the film school and the
business school and we
all worked together to create a new
major called at the time
the business of cinema now called the
business of cinematic arts
and it's a big program now and i was the
first graduate to go through it
and it gave me all of the uh doors
uh opening door openings to uh
start my career in hollywood okay so how
what was the pathway of that career so
you finished film school and then
i mean it's still a long jaunt from
there to where you are right now so you
start out as an assistant
you go and you answer phones and i
answered phones for
talent agents so i answered phones for
the agent
of charlie kaufman and all of these
different major
uh writers and directors and i learned
the business by
by understanding that eventually i
became a manager
a manager is an agent who can also
produce
uh and so i i became a manager started
my company
ended up partnering with a very famous
legendary wrestler named stone cold
steve austin
and with steve uh as an asset
uh i was able to go out and raise a
bunch of money and put together a film
slate
around steve and we went to vancouver
and we made nine movies in four years
wow so um during this time you know
you're you're working with us which
obviously means that you're a
conservative because
it's hard to get anybody else to work
with us so what were your
how did your politics play into this and
yeah what were your were your politics
evident
early or did you become more
conservative over time well so i grew up
in uh a neighborhood that now
houses the bush library uh george w
goes to my church and george w lives ten
blocks from my house so i i come from a
very traditional
conservative neighborhood in dallas uh
called highland park
and when i got to usc it was definitely
eye opening for me
uh to see sort of the more uh
world views and things like that i never
changed i went through
college and my apprenticeship and
becoming a movie producer
always has a pretty open conservative i
avoided social media in the mid-2000s
when it became a thing
because i just never had time for it so
i was always openly conservative
but i wasn't necessarily projecting
all of my thoughts and views onto all of
my friends and their feeds and things
like that
so i i never i never uh changed i was
never shy about it
uh but back then it was more there was
more openness there was a a bigger
there was willingness to have dialogue
and things like that so
i just made great movies that's that's
why that was my focus
and then obviously things have evolved
in hollywood quite a bit
i mean i i know a lot of folks who work
in hollywood and
the mid-2000s even then there there's a
lot of dislike for for anybody who
supported george w bush for sure there
are people who got blacklisted based on
that alone but it's become so much worse
now i mean it is now to the point where
if you forget about supporting trump in
the last two elections
if you so much as express one iota of
descent from the prevailing woke line
there's a chance that they run you out
of town on the rail and you can be just
as liberal as liberal can be on any
other issue so
have you dealt with that shift well i
haven't i've just not dealt with it
i i literally have just stayed pot you
know sort of
quintessentially me uh and so
if you look at the movies that i'm best
known for
uh starting out with bone tomahawk bone
tomahawk is a movie that
is just a great movie it does not
project a political message
there is no agenda to making the movie
it simply exists as entertainment
and as a great piece of content and so
i've always
been very proactive in pushing the best
talents
possible when i was a manager i helped
launch the careers of greta gerwig
leslie hedland
uh you know sean christensen alex
timbers who's one of the biggest
stars on broadway in the directing
community my clients were of all
different shapes and sizes in terms of
political views and world views
but i was always consistent in mine
and so when i started to make movies i
simply made the movies that i
loved as a kid movies that i wanted to
watch
because as time went on less and less
movies were being made
that i could even identify with as an
audience member
so in a second i want to talk to you
about the gap that has emerged in
hollywood between
what people want to make and what people
actually want to see because that gap
has never been wider i think
in the history of the movies we'll get
to that in just one second first we need
to talk about your online
safety and security you absolutely need
to protect your online safety and
security there are hackers out there
they
want your data they're social media
companies they want your data too to
monetize them
the same social media companies they
don't actually want to treat you well
if you can't trust certain elements in
silicon valley to treat conservatives
fairly
how can you trust them to handle your
privacy and personal online data that's
why i recommend using expressvpn
every time you go online big tech
companies can use your ip address to
match your internet activity
to your identity or location when i use
expressvpn search engines and media
sites they can't even see my ip address
at all
my identity is masked and anonymized
expressvpn
has the added benefit of encrypting 100
of your data to keep you safe from
people
who you don't want to have that data in
the first place expressvpn software
takes just a minute to set up on your
computer or phone
you tap one button you're now protected
so if you're like me and you believe
that your internet data belongs to you
not to giant tech companies who are not
friendly to conservatives expressvpn is
indeed
the answer it's always a good idea to
protect yourself from bad people on the
interwebs and in real life this is why
you need expressvpn protect your online
activity today
with the vpn i trust to keep my data
safe visit expressvpn.com
ben to claim an exclusive offer just for
my fans that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
for three months free with a one-year
package visit expressvpn.com
ben to get started okay so let's talk
about politics and
the movie-making business right now so
it used to be that
you know it was very obvious that
hollywood had a leftward lean even from
its content certainly
executives have been left leaning for as
long as i have been
alive um but hollywood used to try to
cater to the audience a lot better than
i think it does right now now basically
hollywood breaks down into two
categories
there's the 300 million dollar superhero
flick which is designed to be a tentpole
action film and that brings in everybody
of all ages
or it is some unbelievably woke piece
that is designed specifically for the
critics or to win an academy award and
now if you want to win an academy award
you have to fulfill certain basic
criteria about
who is featured in the story what the
story is supposed to say i mean formally
they they issued those those regulations
this time around which leads to movies
like the shape of water being somehow
greenlit made and then widely acclaimed
despite being
literally the worst piece of dreck i've
ever seen so what exactly has happened
to the movie industry
uh to create the gap the and it's really
an open gap now between the audience
and on the one hand and and the critics
and and people in hollywood who are
making these films on the other
basically hollywood continues to move
further left and further left
and i stayed the same and so by them
moving left
they're quintessentially moving me to
the right and by me i mean
movies like mine directors that
make movies like mine and audiences that
that
so love the types of movies that we make
so again i think it's more about the
cultural shift than the actual movies
themselves
um but but hollywood is is is
essentially
creating this culture and they're
they're they're constantly hijacking the
narrative so what i
what i'm trying to do is i'm trying to
just hold the line
right i'm trying to pla plant the flag
in the sand and say
these movies should be continued uh
these movies should should continue to
be made
they should exist and we should
celebrate them
no matter what any of the critics are
thinking or pushing back on but i think
you got to go backwards
so when i got to hollywood you know i
was inspired by the jerry bruckheimer's
of the world the robert evans of the
world
nowadays they would be considered
populist producers
uh back then they were mainstream and
they were pushing these amazing movies
and celebrated
when i got to hollywood in the early
2000s it was starting to become
extremely corporate
right so there wasn't there was an
insecurity
from anyone who had a maverick attitude
and you started to become
company men and women in that space over
time
the corporate fear of getting called out
or cancelled by the extreme
left voices and as the you know rise of
social media and twitter and things like
that
over time the the corporations
became so afraid that they started to
simply make
whatever movies the left wanted them to
make and was demanding of them
and so that it's the corporatization of
hollywood combined with the
advent of social media and the extreme
voices on the left
pushing hollywood completely far to the
left where i don't even recognize it
anymore
so what do you think the relationship
between politics and film should be
because
there's some films that are very
political and are pretty good most of
the ones that are overtly political
seem to suck pretty wildly and that
seems to be true on both sides
that folks on the right who seem to want
only altar calls don't realize that the
all-star calls tend to not be very good
movies
and on the left increasingly they're
making altar calls we just have this
competing
series of altar calls what should the
movies be doing how should politics play
into the movies
well anytime you bring politics into
movies or even art
it tends to sort of uh poison the
opportunity there
to change hearts and minds right so
people can argue with me that art is
always political or whatever
movies are all i've always been
political that may be
but when it's so overt and when it's so
one-sided and so partisan
and the community is is 97
one one point of view it becomes
a it almost becomes a a a joke on to
itself
right it becomes a parody of itself and
so i think hollywood is
in its own parody moment right now and
so i think
the the the more we can push politics
out
that would be better for the movies but
it's not possible
it's not possible they won't let it
happen
and we we will to
to make movies for the audiences that my
movies
you know tend to cater to or the ones
that they tend to love
you're going to have to draw a line in
the sand
and pick a side and that's what's
happening right now
i didn't start this fire right i've
always been the same i've always been
doing my thing
as they come after my movies and my
world view and and the way that i
operate as a movie industry and
as a small business owner continuing to
push my
uh movies into a narrative i'm going to
fight back
and i'm sick of it and i won't let it
happen anymore so
it's i'll either uh continue to try
and work with them or i will continue to
make my own movies more and more
independently over time
and if that's the case great so as
you've been
working independently you've still been
able to work with a bevy of big name
stars ranging from kurt russell to
vince vaughn uh the thomas jane and run
hide fight
these are all people who are well
recognized has it has it provided an
obstacle
for you in terms of hollywood and people
you've been able to work with so i don't
really see obstacles
i don't really acknowledge them so i i'm
a run into the burning building kind of
guy and figure it out as we go along so
if if there are people putting up
obstacles in front of me
i'll figure out an end around or i'll
just run right through them i don't
really care
i don't really operate that way and and
that is the
only way this will work if you have this
mentality
where you're going to get this movie
made no matter what
so i with with run hide fight in
particular
i raised all the money independently i
put the
whole movie together with with literally
no help
keep in mind i mean this is a great
script and it attracted great cast and
it was never
easy even going back to bone tomahawk i
had to mortgage my house to get the
movie made
i had to sign a personal loan that i
guaranteed
that i could not pay back if if it had
all gone south
so the amount of uh risk i'm willing to
take
to push forward and continue to making
these movies
whether it ends up sort of uh making
the obstacles bigger and bigger over
time so be it
i won't change and i'm happy and i'm
doing my thing and i'm loving it
so what's your advice for conservatives
in hollywood so i know hundreds of
conservatives who are still working
undercover in hollywood
i know very big name conservatives in
hollywood who i've gotten together with
uh like we got together originally you
know wearing baseball caps at a coffee
bean you didn't care but
i i'd warned you just like i warned
everybody when i got together with them
that if ever a photo is snapped of us
that it becomes
a major issue just as i've warned every
other hollywood person who's ever come
on this show
and you know so what's your advice to
hollywood people
who happen to be conservative about what
they should be doing there as i become
more vocal uh
with my world views and things like that
uh
it's actually opened up a lot of uh
doors for people to come and find me
so i've been getting phone calls from
actors directors
even executives and things things like
that saying
you know here i'm stuck in la right i
want to work with you i love your movies
can we make a movie together
but then there's also the people who
call me and say i'm too afraid right
i've got a mortgage i've got kids in
private school
i rely on my salary what do i do and i'm
so
frustrated right now and what i tell
them is
you have a choice you have the you know
the proverbial robert frost
poem you know you have to pick one of
the two
routes and you can go into the hollywood
route
and they will pay you for your
conformity
they will pay you for your hard work and
your
commitment to their system and their
agendas and everything like that
or you can go completely independent
but if you go independent you come out
and you wave the flag
and show yourself they're going to come
after you
in a way that most people cannot handle
right
uh it's the attacks are so brutal and
they're so often
and they're so constant keep in mind
uh when i am uh with my family
on the weekend or when i'm in the office
building my company
my enemies are on twitter attacking me
24 7. and i can't keep up with that
so i have to tune it out and just keep
going
uh so the advice i give to anyone in in
hollywood who who is is conservative and
confused about what to do
is you have to understand the
ramifications of emerging out with your
thoughts
and hopefully we can take enough time to
build
a real competitive industry a real
conservative
alternative to hollywood that will allow
people
to make enough money to feed their
families and have good jobs
and build this industry up in a way that
really uh five years ago these movies
wouldn't have been political at all
so in a second i want to ask you uh
about some of the controversy that have
been trained on you
um specifically controversies
surrounding cinestate uh
and uh and the other companies that you
are the head of we'll talk about that in
just one second first
let's talk about how you send your mail
so here is the thing you don't
want to do things in stores that you can
do online
right now that is the thing we learned
in 2020 the internet is even more
awesome and useful
than we thought in the first place
getting groceries online movies online
doctor visits online and of course
going to the post office online with our
friends at stamps.com stamps.com allows
businesses to do all of their mailing
and shipping directly
from their computer no need to leave
your home or office
or your home office stamps.com has saved
small businesses all over the country
thousands of hours and
tons and tons of money and now you can
do the same with sams.com you get the
services of
the post office and ups directly from
your computer plus
get big discounts on mailing and
shipping rates here at daily wire we've
been using stamps.com since 2017 we're
not going to waste our time or waste our
money that's how we remain
profitable is by making sure we are
efficient and stamps.com
helps us out simply use your computer to
print official us postage 24 7 for any
letter any package any class email
anywhere you want to send it once your
mail is ready just schedule a pick up or
drop it off
it is indeed that simple so make 2021
the year you stop wasting time going to
the post office and instead head on over
to stamps.com there's no risk and with
my promo code shapiro you get a special
offer that includes a four-week trial
plus free postage and
digital scale no long-term commitments
or contracts just go to stamps.com click
on the microphone at the top of the
homepage type in shapiro that is
stamps.com
promo code shapirostamps.com never go to
the post office again
okay so obviously there were a couple of
big controversies in the last year in
which the media
uh had these these reports in dallas
magazine uh and in the daily beast
uh regarding cinestate it ended with uh
some
some real conflagration at your company
and maybe you can talk about that and
lay that out for folks who missed it
what actually happened there so
we we talk a lot in in the conservative
entertainment industry
about uh unity and we talk about
uh you know is art political do movies
become political
you know um i was trying to create a
company
that was all things for everyone so
cinestate made movies across the board
we made extremely liberal movies under
the fangoria banner a famous horror
iconic logo and then we made
more conservative films or at least you
know
sort of less woke more based movies out
outside of the center state label and
then even created rebeller
which was sort of our sort of response
to
to to fangoria which is great i thought
i could house it all under this one
umbrella
and everyone would get along and what a
joke that became because
no one wanted to get along they didn't
want to be
associated with the other side they
didn't want to find
a shared common ground and resources and
so it was the great experiment going
wrong i pushed back it first and then i
just said okay let me take a break
i'm gonna let this die out and i'm gonna
i'm gonna come
strong in the new year i've got a new
company called bonfire legend
it's representative of my ethos as a
movie producer
i'm rocking and rolling i'm as excited
about
making movies as ever and i'm as
confident in my
uh decisions then uh and now
uh to keep going so let's talk about
your movie-making strategy so one of the
things that you've done that's that's
very different
is of course you've produced all of the
films that you've made on these
incredibly
low budgets and your entire movie
strategy has been very different from
the hollywood movie strategy which is
you spend 20 million dollars on a movie
and because you have hundreds of
millions of dollars out there in
investor capital you can afford to blow
20 million dollars on a movie and if it
fails it fails yeah and you can throw
out 150 million dollars and doctor
doolittle and if it fails it fails
uh and you know it's really been about
the amount of money you blow is is
almost irrelevant
to the to the final product or to the or
to what you're attempting to do right
and now the market it looks like it's
going to come back into place and and
people are going to be really hurting in
the near future because of the death of
the theaters
which i want to ask you about but what
is your strategy especially your
strategy's been different and what is it
how does it relate to kind of the
changes in technology we've seen in
consumption
so any of the movies we've made should
have been made on a 5x multiple budget
so bone tomahawk was made for 1.8 it
should have been made for 10 million
dollars
the great wizardry of
my movie producing style
is that we make these movies for what
they're supposed to be made for
that's a that's a phrase hollywood
doesn't understand
that's a phrase the movie industry
doesn't understand even the independent
space
there's so many people losing money on
independent movies because they come in
they spend a bunch of money they don't
have a marketing plan they don't have a
distribution plan they don't know their
audience
they make it for tons of millions of
dollars and then they lose everything
sometimes that's a mortgage payment
sometimes it's a tax write-off
it depends on the movie i don't like
losing
my movie investors money i like a
batting average where i can say
we've returned the investors money over
and over again on our movies pretty
successfully
and so what we do is we go out and we
figure out the value of the movie
right we go out and we figure out the
foreign sales value
the domestic sales value what the actors
value is we bring it all together
we and we come up with a budget based on
that
now someone joked to me the other day
that that is the jeb bush of movie
making
right no one wants to vote for jeb bush
with his you know
uh uh quiet ideas and you know
thoughtful proposals
you know they everyone wants to be you
know bold and and brash in their movie
making
but the truth is like that's how we keep
this sustainable
by making movies that make money over
and over again
so that's i make the movies as small as
can be
so i have total freedom which i then
transfer to the director
a great cast i can trust my own
instincts on it and if we
fail no one loses their house
so in one second i want to ask you about
the movie that we have released together
over at dailywire.com become a member so
that you can check that out run hide
fight we'll get to that in just one
second first
here's the deal if you want to make your
employment base better well you need to
post a job on zip recruiter because when
you post a job on zipper queer it gets
sent out to over 100 top
job sites with one click then zip
recruiters matching technology scans
thousands of resumes and profiles to
send you the most qualified people for
your job
if you're really interested in a
candidate you can invite them to apply
for that job with one click
zip recruiter sends them an email from
you you stand out from the competition
it's so effective that four out of five
employers who post unzip recruiter get a
quality candidate through the site
within the very first day businesses
have pivoted during this pandemic
becoming more efficient they have to
make sure they are hiring only the best
people you should do the same
over at ziprecruiter.com and right now
you can try zip recruiter for free at
ziprecruiter.com
ben guest that's ziprecruiter.com
b-e-n-g-u-e-s-t just go to
ziprecruiter.com because i do in fact
have a guest ziprecruiter the smartest
way to hire go check them out right now
let's talk about run hide fight because
that is what has brought us together so
uh i remember us meeting i think that
you
basically texted me or emailed me out of
the blue and said that you would listen
to the show
and i of course was aware of of your
movies and i i knew about bone tomahawk
of course and i knew about the vince
vaughn flicks that you'd done
uh and uh we ended up getting together
at basically a coffee bean as i always
say the coffee bean where all great
business gets done
take it from there well the rest is
history yeah i i uh
found a mutual friend who knew us and
reached out to you because
i i was so happy you were uh
liking our movies and promoting them
without uh
any any sort of push on our end on your
show uh
standoff at sparrow creek and braun
cellblock99 so i was so happy and uh
so i had to get to know you and so yeah
so we met
and what was so interesting was we
talked about movies we talked about
politics
and then at the end i said you know we
need to make a movie together
and you you were so great you said yes
let's do it
and i said um you know i'm gonna figure
some stuff out i'm gonna bring you some
things you go
look if you don't wanna put our name on
it i totally get it i understand we can
bring you know
and i was like are you kidding we're
gonna put your name all over it
hopefully
you're going to become an executive
producer on it now over the
over the year we sort of stayed in touch
here and there and run height fight was
not originally
a daily wire movie but what happened was
i was i i recalled that conversation
and i and i recalled the feeling i had
when i was speaking to you
that i could trust you and that i i felt
a kindred spirit and someone who was in
the fight with me
and so i was so excited in fact
and god has his ways the response to the
movie
from the critical community which was so
perverted and the ultimate
challenges in selling the movie to a
traditional hollywood distributor
open the door for me to contact you
again
and say literally i think you should
come on board this movie and distribute
it
and then the rest is history so let's
talk about the the critical response
and we're going to try and do this whole
conversation with those spoilers that
people actually
become members just to see the movie
because that of course is how we all get
paid
but the the movie was produced a couple
of years ago right
yeah and uh and then a year ago a year
ago and then it comes out at venice
uh and the response from the critics is
absolutely as vicious as it can possibly
be essentially
uh so what what drove that and what was
the critical response well so i i've
made 30 plus movies
i know what a good movie is run hide
fight is a great
movie it is great i know it
i know it i know it and so when i went
to venice
i never understood that the critics were
going to
attack the movie based on a perception
of politics
and a subject matter issue right now
they'll hide it
under the guise of creative whims or
this or that or they didn't
like the movie or the writing or
whatever but i call bs on that
now it's it's tricky because i hate when
directors are kind of like you know
lashing back on critics but this was a
this was not
one critique this was a common thread
amongst
all the critics and so i'm lashing back
at the overall
narrative placed on these reviews
which was subject matter and you don't
review subject matter
in my opinion people can argue with me
on that
made a great movie it was destroyed by
the critics
yet the people who've seen the movie
and in fact ironically the daily beast
movie critic in italy wrote us our best
review
because they aren't biased they're not
their experience watching the movie is
not perverted
by years of hating donald trump
and hating conservatives and all of
these things
so look that's the hand we're dealt
we're going to cry about it or are we
going to do something about it and so
that's why
i was i was thinking if i release this
with a traditional distributor i don't
need a crystal ball to see what's going
to happen to us
it's going to happen anyway might as
well call ben and do it with him
so let's talk about the subject matter
so it's obviously controversial subject
matter
obviously the basic plot premise of the
film is a
school takeover by school shooters and
we at daily wire are intensely focused
on not encouraging school shootings the
entire film
in my view is a diatribe against school
shootings and the media coverage of
school shootings we were
one of the first sites in america to
declare that we would not name mass
shooters under any circumstances because
we don't want to give them publicity and
that is
in fact one of the angles of the film is
that one of the great evils of our
society is giving attention to these
folks because that's what they seek
more than anything else maybe you can
talk about the subject matter and angle
of the film
well the subject matter is very personal
to me so i
have lost both of my parents to domestic
gun violence
in separate instances
almost unfathomable to even say it out
loud it's a sentence that doesn't even
make sense
my mother was killed in her home
in 2010 by her husband as she was
packing her bags to leave him
and divorce him my dad was killed in
by a hitman in lubbock texas
hired by the ex-boyfriend
of the woman he was dating at the time
totally unrelated
both of them caught completely off guard
in their own homes and killed where
you should be the safest and so i have
carried that
with me that that feeling of
of of loss tragedy sadness
for so long and i was looking for a
movie
that i felt i could put some of that
energy into so when the script for run
height fight came my way
i was so excited about it
it was about to be sold as a spec script
to a major studio
and then parkland happened and then they
pulled out
of course that's when i get the call
because that's when i get the call for
every script is when everyone else
passes but they know it's a good script
it just needs someone bold enough to be
willing to make it
so i said this script deserves to be
made
i'm going to take the personal
responsibility
of the movie even beyond the director
even beyond the actors
even beyond my producers and everything
like that because i have lived
with the personal tragedy of losing not
one but two
parents to violence and gun violence
and so i'm going to take the
responsibility i'm i'm going to shelter
the movie
and we're going to make it in my system
with independent money so that i can
make it totally unperverted
right no one no one can touch it i'll
i'll shield it from from all the
external influences and that's what we
did
the movie's great it's important
and i think it's going to shock
some people the lockdown procedures the
idiocy
of the reactions and the way that
schools have to react and the policies
there
if we do anything with this movie if we
can just
shine a spotlight on the
policies and make them better around the
reactions to school shootings and
keeping our schools and our children
safe
then i'm thrilled beyond that it is a
wildly entertaining movie
and i don't believe that
you cannot be entertained and watch a
movie like this
so you know the as we talked about the
critics
universally savage i'm fully expecting
that
upon release of the film uh there will
be a second wave of critical hatred
for the film which is again one of the
things that has happened
not just to your film but it's happened
to nearly any film these days that does
anything that crosses
the woke i mean we i recently had a
conversation with jd vance author of
hillbilly elegy about how the critics
went after hillbilly elegy
and just burned it to the ground because
the idea behind hillbilly elegy was that
you might want to take some of these
rural white folks seriously and the
critics had decided in the meantime that
nope you know after the movie got
greenlit now was not the time to take
real white folks seriously we couldn't
do that anymore and they decided to just
burn it all the way down so what do you
think is the answer to that because we
are seeing this this vast gap emerge
between what the critics think about
films and what the audiences think about
films
uh hillbilly elegy has 20 some percent
on rotten tomatoes it's got an 85
approval rating among audiences i'm sure
that run hide fight will have a zero
percent or a five percent or 14
on rotten tomatoes and the audience
ratings are going to be above 90 what
what in the
what in the conservative community
should we and the more mainstream
community should
we be doing about those i would love to
take biden at his word for unity
but it's never going to happen it's not
happening so i really believe
that it's it's possible for both sides
to work together
to get along and to make movies and work
in the same workplace
i totally believe it's it's possible but
i also think we're entering into
probably an eight-year period of
tribalism and people sort of going into
their own corners
and i think that if people want to watch
movies like this and continue to
consume content that isn't preaching a
message to them
and jamming a sort of a secular world
view down their throats
then they have to support a conservative
economy
and by that i mean everything a
conservative hollywood alternative
any of it right so i think ultimately
uh you know it it has to
i don't like it i i don't
i didn't want this to i thought i was
going to be you know living in la
running a movie studio by by now and
here i am
uh you know in my own independent lane
but in a way i'm happier now than i ever
would have been there
and i know those people they're still my
friends
they're unhappy they're insecure
they're confused about the lockdowns
and living in california under gavin
newsom they're confused about all this
they they're moving to texas they're
calling me
even my sort of lovely liberal friends i
and
and i'm encouraging them get out and
it's across the board
if your company is pushing
a critical race theory on you get out of
that company
if you're going to a college and your
professor
is pushing an agenda on you speak
up and push back now i know i have a
privileged position because of my
stature and my financial situation and
things like that so i understand it's
tough
but i promise you we will create enough
infrastructure
on the other side of the fence to give
landing pads
and and and uh places to work and make
movies
for people who don't want to work in
that industry anymore
and i'm still in the industry right now
i've got a movie at new line
that they say they're going to make this
year i sold a movie to netflix it's
coming out in a couple of months
i i've got a movie with uh you know the
folks who made john wick i mean i
i'm still in the business right i talk
to the agencies all
the time so i'm still one foot and one
foot out
but if i had to choose today i'm out
and i'm going this direction and i'm so
excited about it i think it's going to
be a big move so let's talk about the
changes to the market and also
how we prepare conservative audiences
for having to think this way because i
think conservative audiences
have never really thought seriously
about engaging in the culture in
this way because there really have been
no alternatives we'll get to that in
just one second first
here's the thing life insurance it's
super important if you are an adult
human with dependence
god forbid something should happen to
you they don't just lose you they lose
your income you need
life insurance so if getting life
insurance is on your to-do list for 2021
policy genius can help you cross it off
with ease policy genius makes it easy
for you to compare
more than 30 top insurers at once and
save over 50 in the process plus
there's no hassle because they're
licensed experts work for you not the
insurance companies
so here is how it works first head on
over to policygenius.com in minutes you
can work out
how much coverage you need and compare
quotes from top insurers to find
your best price policy genius and
compares policies starting at as little
as a buck a day you might even be
eligible to skip that in-person medical
exam
once you apply the policy genius team
will handle all the paperwork and the
red tape
if you hit any speed bumps during the
application process they'll take care of
everything soup to nuts that kind of
service
has earned policy genius a five-star
rating across over 1 600 reviews
on trustpilot and google you do need to
protect the people who rely
on you god forbid something should
happen to you you need life insurance
make this the year you finally cross
life insurance off your list get
protection for your loved ones go to
policygenius.com and get started you
could save 50
or more by comparing quotes and start
the new year with one less thing to
worry about policy genius when it comes
to insurance it's nice and very very
important to get it right
okay so one of the things obviously that
we are focusing on as we shift into
entertainment at daily wire is trying to
let conservative audiences know exactly
what you're talking about that you have
to stop thinking about
entertainment is just a thing you do in
your off hours the same as everybody
else because the entertainment community
is not thinking about you that way the
entertainment community
very often sees you as the enemy they
see you as the bad guy
and they are looking to both preach to
you and insult you
at the exact same time and so you're
going to need to engage with
with entertainment the way the left
engages with entertainment which is that
unless you are the intransigent
group of people who wish who want to see
the stuff you want to see
you're not going to get to see any of
that stuff how do we convince
conservatives
that you know without making overt
conservative altar calls
you still are going to have to engage
with a different type of entertainment
and put your money where your mouth is
if you don't want to see hollywood take
over the entire culture
it's never in our uh nature as
conservatives
to rally together because we are so
individualistic
that it's not in our nature as
conservatives to fight back
because we're worried about protecting
our family and conserving
right so what we have to realize
is that you're in the middle of a
culture war
now and a culture war now leads to a
political war
later and it is coming for you
the cavalier executives in hollywood
hate you they hate your kind
they hate your churches they hate your
guns they hate
all of it they are hell-bent
on pushing their narrative and
destroying anything that doesn't
totally serve their agenda so
you have to fight back and there's
interesting ways you can do it because
not everyone has the platform that you
have or the movie producing career that
i have
so what do you do if you're if you're if
you're just a a
person who loves movies and loves
freedom of speech and loves america
well a few things you support
the companies that support us right
so i do it all the time i didn't watch
an hour of nba basketball or the nfl
season this year i'm the biggest sports
fan in the world
and it hurt not to be able to watch my
dallas cowboys on sunday
but i turned it all off and for one
second
not a second conversely
i made a bunch of purchases this year
simply safe black rifle coffee the pearl
source i i'm i'm all in
right so you can make these you know
real commitments to
promoting the conservative companies
that share your world view
because ultimately it ain't politics
it's world view it is secular world view
versus biblical world view
it is uh you know sort of an individual
freedom
versus group think and thought police
and all these different things
we've got to fight back because if we
don't it's just going to keep going and
keep going it's just creeping in and it
we're beyond creep now it's it's
overwhelming
so i just said enough and i i i ripped
off the mask and said let's go
let's go do this so one of the things
that i'm really optimistic about is
again the change in
the level of technology that is
necessary in order to do this it used to
be you had to have
not only a movie studio behind you a big
movie studio with tons of money but you
also had to have a distribution system
that would put your movie in 300
theaters now or a thousand theaters or
2000 theaters
and now it seems like the movie
experience because of covid it was
already dying and now it looks like
there's just been a stake put through
its heart which means that the entire
hollywood system
is about to crumble from within i mean
so much of their budget is reliant
on spending oodles of money on a big
tentpole film they can then put out in
theaters for
and and make 150 million dollars in a
weekend and now they can't do that
anymore and they're having to falsify
statistics about how much money they're
making off individual movies on netflix
if you watch 30 seconds of a movie on
netflix it's exactly the same
as you spent 20 bucks at a theater to
watch a marvel film so i think that's
opening up some real opportunities and i
think they're moving into a space in
which you're the pro and in which you
are actually the 400 pound gorilla
they say it takes 60 days to break a bad
habit in 30 days to make a new habit
we're so far beyond that time
line in terms of covid and the way that
we see the world and the way that we
operate on a daily basis
i believe that movie theaters are done i
think that uh
back in even march when universal
sort of messed with the windowing
between the time a movie comes out in
theaters and when it comes out online
or on vod i think they they
that was the death nail uh to theaters
even back then i felt it
and now months later and months later
these movie theaters they're
so in debt they have hundreds of
millions of dollars of debt
insurmountable debt and people don't
want to come
back to movie theaters right now they
just don't there's too
much fear i myself have seen six movies
in theaters and every time i go
i'm the only person in the movie theater
unless i went with someone
and so it's over now that's good and bad
i'm going to miss movie theaters i'm a
movie theater guy
i'm a physical media you know by the
blu-ray kind of guy like i'm traditional
in that sense i love
going to the movie theater and having a
full audience and the popcorn the whole
experience
but the truth is my kids they don't they
don't even know what it is
they've gone to movie theaters many
times but it's not it's not in their
soul
right and their generation so it's all
going to become a home entertainment
play
the good news is it levels the playing
field for everyone
it's like the music industry i couldn't
tell you
what label released the last
200 albums that i've downloaded right i
couldn't even tell
you so it's really important now
that we put out enough content
to compete with netflix build up that
brand
servicing our audience in a way where we
can
get them to expect great movies from us
is if you look at the the movies that
conservatives have generally been fed
they tend to be sort of overtly
political or overtly christian
nothing wrong with either of those and i
have great respect for the people who
work in those industries and they are my
friends
but i believe that we make better movies
and i believe that we can figure out how
to create
a real momentum a real movement
uh in movies that aren't necessarily
conservative but simply are not
woke yeah i think one of the big moves
here is going to be toward
better writing i'm hoping in hollywood
just because they've talked about how
it's the golden age of tv
for a while because the writing has
gotten so much better on tv than it is
in many of the movies but
movies were so reliant on giant
spectacle and foreign marketing in china
and all of this
that now that the theater experience in
the united states is largely dead it
doesn't matter to you if you're watching
a hundred million dollars on your phone
right the the the the only thing that
matters is whether it's watchable on the
phone
the special effects don't look the same
when they are held in your hand as they
are when they're projected on a giant
imac screen
i also think the phone is uh at times is
even
uh sort of over um focused on
we focus too much on the phones i still
think the movie theater
television screen is is still the key um
so i think if if you have provocative
movies
with great writing great acting a really
compelling story
and good producing because you got to
bring it you know all together
i think that's really exciting and then
just putting out the movie with daley
wire
we're reaching an audience size that
we've never reached on a movie before
ever ever not even bone tomahawk not
brawl and cell block 99
not dragged across concrete none of
those movies in one week
have reached as many people
as daily wire with run hide fight as
those movies have in their entire
runs so this is such an exciting thing
and i just want to keep doing it because
uh you know even just the trailer
numbers are
out the roof instantly so your access to
the audience through daily wire and your
own show
i think is so key because they trust you
and then
if we can continue to bring them great
content
that is exciting and entertaining
i think that there will be a real
opportunity here in the marketplace
to kind of take some of the focus away
from traditional big hollywood
so in a second i want to ask you about
uh some of the other movies that you've
made what are your favorites and also i
want to i want to ask about the level of
violence in the films because
conservatives are always
uh sort of complaining about levels of
violence and films your films are
certainly not shy
when it comes to the when it comes to
the bloodshed so we'll get to it in just
one second
first let's talk about your sleep
quality it has been awesome and getting
unboxing videos from so many of you who
found
the helix mattress of your dreams helix
sleep mattresses they are the best
it's very easy they have a two-minute
sleep quiz you take it and then they
provide a mattress made just
for you it is fantastic if you sleep hot
if you sleep
cold if you sleep soft or if you need a
very firm bed helix can make it all
happen just for you they'll send you the
mattress that you've matched to
mattress comes directly to your door
shipped for free you don't ever need to
go to a mattress store again
helix is awesome you don't need to take
my word ford helix is awarded the number
one best overall mattress pick
of 2020 by both gq and wired magazine so
just head on over to
com slash ben take that two minute sleep
quiz i'll match you to that customized
mattress it'll give you
the best sleep of your life they've got
a 10-year warranty you have to try it
out for a hundred nights at risk-free
they'll even pick it up for you if you
don't love it but that's not going to
happen you're going to love the mattress
helix
is offering up to 200 bucks off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners
at helixsleep.comixsleep.com
bennett go check them out right now at
helixsleep.com
as a big fan of all of your films i can
definitely say that none of them are for
kids who are under the age of maybe 15
years old yeah uh
at a minimum boom tomahawk uh is a movie
that uh
i loved and also would not watch with my
wife because
she is she's a bit skittish when it
comes to the violence and bone tomahawk
is definitely not skittish when it comes
to the violence
so how should how should conservatives
think about themes like that it seems to
me that
hollywood owns the space because
conservatives have given up the space
and so instead of being so um
instead of being so puritant about the
kind of stuff that people watch we
should just acknowledge what people
watch and then compete in that space
i think if you look at a traditional
hollywood uh
conservative viewer going back to the
70s and 80s
i think they liked a lot of movies that
were pretty violent
command all the schwarzenegger movies
stallone rambo
going back to the 70s even with the
godfather these are great movies
and i just think that that
audience has been forgotten right now as
as we bring them back into the fold of
watching movies
i think that there's always going to be
a skepticism right
conservative movies tend to be
too too too sort of overtly political or
they tend to have sort of a
quality of writing that just isn't
competitive
let's fix that right bring them back
into the fold now in terms of the
violence
keep in mind i was making movies that
would go through a traditional hollywood
distributor
for vod and have no marketing
so the movies themselves were the
marketing and so i think
most of the movies i was making were
that violent because
i needed a hook or i needed a a an
inflection point or something to go
viral
um and also just just the the filmmakers
that i was attracted to
and continue to be attracted to their
work um
you know happened to be that and and
let's be honest i was processing the
death of my parents
you know the deaths of my parents so i
think if you
look at my body of work 10 years from
now i think it will level out a little
bit in terms of the violence
but in terms of the conservative
audience give it a chance
it's it's there's always a level of
provocation and
entertainment to any movie but
the it's it the violence in our movies
is
almost clinical in its realistic and
commitment to authenticity
so we're no different in many ways than
almost a
sort of a documentarian in that sense
but i look forward to seeing
you know everyone's reaction because
yeah it's very violent
we make we make violent movies i mean i
i think that this is this is part of the
general appeal that conservatives are
also going to have to understand is to
younger people
uh and that is that younger people are
used to a certain level of edginess
and violence and pushing the envelope
and the stuff that they watch
and so if we're going to make this move
over a daily wire
into the entertainment field we want to
be pushing the envelope we want to be
arguing in favor of why 17 or 18 21 year
olds should be watching our stuff
you know there's lots of great material
over at hallmark channel but that's not
exactly what we're seeking to do
you know what we're seeking to do is
reach out to audiences who have opened
up to the hollywood experience because
they're looking for
edgy cool interesting suspenseful
uh and uh and drawing people when
they're young is the way that you're
gonna eventually dissuade them from
entering the culture on the other side
that's absolutely right i think two
things on that front one
uh the millennial generation will
ultimately
flow through the advertising demographic
the 18 to 34.
that will take time and uh ultimately
the pendulum always swings back
right so i think if we look at the early
data on gen z
and gen alpha and the younger generation
i think they're going to push back
on some of the general sort of
stereotypical millennial
reactions and behavior so i have a hope
for our children
if you look at history it tends to
repeat itself
and hollywood in the late 1960s
was in the toilet right there they were
making these
giant war epics with you know uh
and musicals and it was all falling flat
it was irrelevant
and income the new hollywood in the late
latest 60s earliest 70s and they
arguably created some of the best movies
in the world
you know all the filmmakers scorsese
coppola spielberg de palma um
dennis hopper uh peter bogdanovich all
those guys certainly
but there were uh a couple of producers
that helped launch this movement
and they're uh they're called the bbs
guys bob rafelson bert schneider and
steve
browner and they they ushered in
this new generation by producing easy
rider
and five easy pieces those movies
appealed to a younger audience that was
sick
of the mainstream nonsense that
hollywood was putting out at the time
and so i really want to take a page from
their playbook
and sort of reinvent this youthful uh
you know vi vibrant hollywood uh
movie making which appeals to a younger
audience that simply
isn't interested in what uh the major
studios are putting out right now
so my great hope beyond obviously
conservatives getting involved in
entertainment is
hopefully moderates and and even some
some folks on the left good hearted
liberals
will watch the movies and maybe they
will be able to forge a connection and
entertainment that's been foreclosed
from the other side i know that uh that
may be
too much to hope for at the beginning
but i i do hope that
if hollywood is going to seed all of
this ground and decide the cop shows
they're off limits and need to be
removed from tv
and the traditional narratives are just
too much for people to handle because
they're not woke enough
they're opening an awful lot of ground
for people like you to fill in
for both of us i i know for certain that
after
we announced this deal on both sides our
our emails
in boxes have been flooded and our phone
calls have been flooded with
people reaching out saying finally thank
you
right for every sort of aggressively
mean
tweet that we get we get two to three
emails
in the positive manner people saying i'm
so happy this is finally happening
right so i know the audience is out
there my movies
do so well in middle america
we sell out at walmart they have to
reorder the dvds the dvds
okay it's like you wonder who are the
people watching
ncis uh every week and it's my aunts and
uncles and cousins in shreveport
louisiana
real salt of the earth great people who
i love sharing thanksgiving with
and i just this is my family this is the
world i know
this is the audience i know and they're
they're mostly conservative
and some moderates and things like that
and i think there's such an
awesome opportunity to start sharing
movies with them again and making movies
for that audience
they're going to eat it up and they're
so excited about it
let's talk about what it was like to
work on the set of run hide fight how
did that shoot go how how was it to work
with isabelle may and thomas jane and
all the rest of the cast
yeah isabelle had auditioned for a movie
of ours before
and i'd always wanted to cast her in
something so when i found run hide fight
and started to put it together and when
we cast the movie i really wanted her in
that role
so i didn't want to sort of push you
know an agenda on kyle so i sort of
let it become the casting director's
idea first and then
you know over time um but i was so happy
we we ended up casting her and then
thomas
uh he had been attached to the project
for a long time
um and really supportive of the movie
and and and of me as a producer and
things like that so
when it all came together we ended up
deciding to make it
about a year ago in texas in a small
town called
red oak we found a middle school that
was decommissioned it was going to be
turned into a youth center
and so we had the whole school totally
empty
to ourselves and man did we blow it up
i mean we just really i mean we
destroyed it
uh you know we with with you know
driving
uh cars through walls and explosions
things like that
so it was a blast it was really one of
the most exciting
times on set uh that i'd had as a movie
producer because
we were making something i knew was
going to be a good movie and
entertaining but also something
felt really important both
for the active shooting response and
trying to really
sort of push that conversation into the
forefront again
but also i felt in my heart
that this was a movie that i had to make
personally
uh to sort of you know celebrate the
legacy of my parents
and their memory uh and their and sort
of honor all the things that they've
done in my life
and i i just can't i can't tell you how
proud i am of the movie i mean it's just
so important to me
well we are of course super excited to
be releasing it with you over at daily
wire it's already there at daily wire
as you watch this subscribe so that you
can hear not only the end of this
conversation but also
so that you can actually see the film
right now i'm going to be asking dallas
a couple more questions starting with a
few of his favorite movies also where he
thinks the future of the country is
politically if if we can actually win
this particular fight if you'd like to
hear
dallas sonia's answers you have to be a
daily wire member so head on over to
dailywire.com and click
subscribe you can hear the rest of our
conversation over there
well dallas thank you so much for
stopping by everybody needs to check out
our newest film
run hide fight available right now only
at dailywire.com
dallas thank you so much for joining the
show it's great to see you thank you for
having me
[Music]
the ben shapiro show sunday special is
produced by mathis glover
executive producer jeremy boring our
technical director is austin stevens and
our assistant director is pavel
wiedowsky
associate producer nick sheehan our
guests are booked by caitlin maynard
editing is by jim nicholl audio is mixed
by mike coromina hair and makeup is by
fabiola cristina
title graphics are by cynthia angulov
the ben shapiro show sunday special is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021